hello everyone thanks for
coming um I appreciate uh you having the
very nice weather this week from my
first visit to Sydney thanks a lot uh my
name is Jimmy you can find me at Twitter
atj Bogard and I promise it's not
entirely untap check-ins there are some
insightful tweets somewhere in there and
uh you can find me at GitHub too at
github.com /j Bogard pretty much
everything I do is on that repository
including every presentation I do so if
you check that out you'll find all the
materials for this as well and a Blog at
loses so you can go to Jimmy bard. L
tees.com and I work at headspring a
consulting company in Texas very far
away from here very very far away and
most people know me because I work on an
open source project called automapper
which we may or may not be talking about
today we'll
see uh so today I want to talk about uh
the new aspn net core framework which is
released right it's not preview2 beta 7
SDK something it's actually out now so
that's good um I want to talk about a
little bit how we build as. net core
applications and one of the interesting
things about the aspnet core framework
besides a ground up rewrite is just like
the old aspnet framework MBC and web API
is completely devoid of any opinions
about how you should build aspn net
applications so what I wanted to do with
this one is take kind of the normal asp9
core application you typically see out
in the wild and wanted to refactor it to
make it more solid solid being the
single responsibility principle the open
close principle something about
inheritance uh interface segregation
principle and then the dependency
inversion principle although some people
just say dependency injection and just
be done with it um I actually don't have
very many slides like this is like the
main one that we're going to go straight
to code so let's just do that sound good
okay so enough of that
and now we'll be using visual studio I'm
not one of those Jokers that says they
code in Visual Studio code or something
like that I'm using a real editor
here okay the first thing I wanted to do
is just go through this controller and
view as it is to just kind of see what
we see and see if there's things that
stick out to us as things we want to try
to fix or remove some of the duplication
make it more solid so this is kind of a
normal uh NVC Style controller it's got
a number of actions as part of it so
there's an index action a details action
a create action with a lot of space
there need some space and then the
normal kind of top level things you
typically see so create edit update
delete and I wanted to take a little
tour of these to see what kind of things
we see stick out to us in terms of
duplication and the stuff that uh just
we see over and over in our typical
applications and just to make sure that
this is a real run running application
I'm going to run it and make sure it
actually actually
works so it does actually have a real
database behind the scenes uh this case
I'm just
showing a list of students nothing
terribly exciting except that I can do
things like edit them so I can go edit
them and and add some additional
information here save and yes indeed it
actually saved I can create a new
students uh how about
me
and my enrollment dates I don't know
today why not uh and then we we would
verify yes indeed it actually did create
me up there so yes this is a real
application with a real database
underneath underneath the covers um so
it probably looks and feels more like
the applications I typically
write so let's look at this controller
here now most applications I run into uh
the MVC applications have do two general
flavors of actions uh there are my git
actions and there are my post actions
the the git actions are going to be
making some sort of query and showing
some data on the screen and then my post
actions of course they're going to be
manipulating some information behind the
covers okay so here's our index action
um it's somewhat complicated because
it's having to do uh sorting filtering
uh pagination as well so my controller
is building up um a result object that
it passes along to the view it takes in
a query here so these are the query
string parameters and after some code
here fing down at the bottom here we go
it's building out my view model in the
ter in the form of a page list that it
passes along to the view so far so
good and then inside my view it's
nothing exciting here it's just building
a table of entries down here and then
displaying that information on the
screen not that exciting there as
well so my G actions more or less look
the same there's there's may or may not
be some sort of inputs for query string
parameters and then builds out some sort
of output now every application that I
build as well is going to have one
single model in and one single model out
one of the reasons I do this is on the
model inside this is a lot more
refactoring friendly so if I add
additional query string parameters it
doesn't necessarily break other parts of
my application that assume a very
specific ordering or naming of those uh
parameters as well so these are all the
query string parameters that could
potentially come in as part of making
that individual
request uh one of the other first things
you should notice as well is that out of
the box I do have dependencies being
injected into my application so in this
case that school context the DB context
from Entity Framework that's being
injected This Time by not not by my own
dependency injection container but
actually from the one out of the box
from ASP MVC core that piece is actually
set
up in our
startup over
here and then a little bit further down
here we
go so that right there is manipulating
the base service collection you can
think that as the thing I stick all my
services into and I'm telling it to add
this DB context of type School context
with some configuration saying I want
you to use SQL server and the connection
string is going to be what I uh pull
from over here this default connection
uh from the configuration manager
here so that kind of checks the d off
the list of my solid out of the box in
older versions of NVC framework it was
pretty annoying to have to deal with the
pendency injection it wasn't out of the
box built in and you usually had to to
poke many different places to make sure
your dependencies got absolutely
everywhere and we'll see with some of
the other extension points here later in
NVC that everything in NVC core is
dependency injection enabled so I can
take those dependencies with just about
everything I use inside of MVC core
including my controller here so D is
down now we can focus on the Sol part of
the
solid all right so let's look further
down uh now at our different uh
controller actions specifically I want
to look at the form posts so I'm look at
the create action
here okay and then the edit action down
here the two form
posts now if I look at these two
controller actions I I uh see some
commonalities here that my form post
will typically take the form of doing
some sort of model State validation so
validation has already occurred let's
say okay is it valid or not and and if
it is valid then let's actually do the
work of the controller action we'll save
some changes and then finally
redirect and if it wasn't valid then I
go ahead and show the view passing in
that model so they can get rehydrated
now nearly every single one of my post
actions looks exactly like this do a
model state check do the actual real
meat of the work save changes and then
go
redirect
now one of the duplications I typically
see in my applications and not the kind
of copy paste variety where it's the
same exact code in two places but it's
more of a concept duplication and the
concept I see here the overall kind of
pattern I have is doing a validation
check doing some work and then saving
some changes so what I'd like to do is
take advantage of some of the extensions
at MVC core to remove this duplication I
see in all of my post
actions so first with the one I want to
get rid of is this right here db. save
changes that's the line of code that is
something you can't ever really forget
to do if you forget to call Save changes
then your changes aren't flush to the
database and then you'll just have some
you know like oh you edited something
and nothing nothing actually changed
behind the scenes and in my applications
if I have to remember to do something
then I'm probably going to forget even
it's it's something as simple as calling
save changes so what I want to do is
build a policy in MVC core so that on
every single request my changes are
always saved to the database and I never
have to remember to call Save changes
ever again so let's do
that um one by the way one of the other
things that you can look at to see am I
violating solid is if you go up to the
top and look at your using statements
and if you see things from a lot of
different places things like uh I've got
things doing with MVC I've got link and
there's Entity framework in there as
well if I see a lot of different
concerns in one single spot it usually
comes out in the form of my using
statements but back to our save changes
what I want to do is take this and put
it into a place in the MVC core pipeline
so that executes an every single
request now similar to aspon at MVC and
web API before it MVC core has the
concept of filters and filters are sets
of code you can execute before and after
every single request at specific Parts
in the execution pipeline so that every
single time it happens on every single
request and what that allows me to do is
that this kind of duplication that I
copy and paste in every single one of my
actions I can pull that out and have
that in one single spot as in the form
of just one single class that then goes
across my entire
application so let's do that now I've
also uh got some cheat code here so I
don't want to uh mistype something so I
actually got it over here in the form of
a
filter and the other thing I want to do
is go into my DB context and add a bit
of code there and I'm going back to my
cheat code here to grab that here we
go so one of the kind of interesting
things about uh ASP um sorry Entity
framework both an Entity framework and
Entity framework core is they try to
hide a lot of the trans action support
behind the scenes I don't really like
that I like to be very explicit about
when a transaction begins and when a
transaction ends as opposed to just kind
of a magical safe changes call of like
well where did The Connection open where
did the transaction open is it is there
one transaction that I do up here and
another one down here I don't like that
I like to have a very explicit boundary
so I'm going to create that boundary by
extending my DB context a little bit
here so let's go to my school
context and and I'm going to add this is
my DB context that I'm using for the
entire application I'm going to add a
few methods to help me build out uh some
transaction
support so I have a I'm exposing a few
methods here one is to begin a
transaction and that'll open up a
transaction behind the scenes down here
uh one of the one of the other things I
like to do is have a very explicit
isolation level in which I'm opening of
the transaction um does anyone know what
the default SQL Server transaction isce
relation
is serializable that's wrong it actually
depends on the version of SQL Server
you're using like even different like
additions of SQL Server will be like
read committed uh serializable I think
snapshot may be a default here pretty
soon I don't it's it's really all over
the place so instead of me relying on
the installed
database default or someone's default
that some DBA puts somewhere I want to
be very explicit about that and that's
what I'm doing here is being very very
explicit about saying I'm opening a
transaction with this specific isolation
level now one thing you could do that I
do on some projects is open up different
isolation levels depending on whether
doing a get or post like you could do a
read uncommitted for a get versus like a
a snapshot for posts um that way you
have you know just different concurrency
models based on the activities you're
trying to perform I'm not going to get
that complicated I'm just going to have
begin transaction
with this specific isolation level and
luckily I'm using en framework core
luckily it's actually exposed um it's
kind of a crapshoot within any framework
core these days about what it actually
has out of the box it's a 1.0 but I
think that's a kind of a loose term with
that
release um I'm also going to expose some
methods to close the transaction um if
there's an exception it'll roll back the
transaction otherwise it'll go ahead and
commit the transaction so all that stuff
that people typically build into like a
unit of work class or something like
that um I like to just stick that right
on the DB context itself as opposed to
building some other abstraction one of
the things I want to highlight here is
that the the solid principles don't mean
abstract everything um it just means put
things in the right place and that's
what I'm trying to do
here okay so back to our
filter uh I declare this MVC transaction
filter to be an async action filter this
doesn't this didn't exist in previous
version of MVC there was no async um so
the MVC core pipeline was completely
rehauled to be async all the way just
like you saw in web API if you have seen
that as
well this filter can now take a
dependency okay so this used to be super
super hard to do in ASP not MVC the
previous version um you couldn't
actually have a filter take dependencies
at all you'd have to do like service
location or put it in a very special
place or I've seen tricks like put it in
HTTP context items anyone ever do that
yes that's like the thing that exists on
every single requests you can stick
stuff in there and have it available for
parts later on the request but that
seemed kind of crazy um other the
interesting thing on filters with uh
previous version of NBC is they were all
Singleton so they were instantiated once
for the entire lifetime of the
application and there was that that that
let down feeling when you realized what
it was doing like oh crap I'm to code
around this well that's not happening
anymore uh NVC is building NVC core is
building out the concept of a
composition rout so that I can have one
single spot where I instantiate
everything for the entire request and
depending on life cycle rules we'll have
things instantiated at different points
so what that means for me is that my
filter can now take a dependency on a DB
context now on the actual filter method
itself the onaction execution
async which I don't know what that means
in real English but I think it's just
when the action executes they have this
kind of weird naming syntax um on their
different methods here so this means
when the action is executing do this
stuff and what it does is it passes in
this delegate which is supposed to be
the next thing to
do
so my filter see if I can get it all on
the screen here here we
go has a try catch it's going to first
await against opening the transaction
with a B begin transaction method then
it's going to call await next and that
next is the next thing in the MVC
pipeline so it may be another filter it
may be executing the action um that's
all encapsulated for me in terms of my
individual filter here I don't care it's
just the next thing to do after that
next thing is done then I go ahead and
close the
transaction that would commit the
transaction and if any exception occurs
then I'll go ahead and roll back by
passing in that exception I'm seeing
this now and I probably should have
named those like commit and roll back
but hindsight is 2020 we'll edit that
out later I'm
sure okay so now that I've declared my
filter I can then go register that in
part of my
startup so something else new in asp.net
MVC core are the ability to configure
directly using this configure services
in previous versions of NVC you had all
these static classes you were dealing
with like the bundle config the filter
config all those config classes remember
those things you don't have those
anymore now you have a single spot where
you can specify all your MVC core
configuration and that's I'm going to do
right here so I'll do my little
configuration block and I'll say config
do
filters do add and I can tell it the
type of filter I want to add so this
this case it's going to be type of MVC
transaction filter that
one now because I'm giving it the filter
type and not a filter instance MVC knows
that it needs to instantiate that filter
every single time for each request
that's what I
want okay so now with that filter in
place I can go back to my controller and
remove some of these SA
changes so in my post actions create oh
save changes
goodbye edit save changes goodbye and
delete save changes goodbye as
well so what I've just done there is
removed some of the responsibilities
from my controller of knowing when to
call Safe changes and and commit those
to the database I've removed those and
put it in one single class so that's the
s in solid for having a single
responsibility for managing the
transaction scope for my
application oh but let's make sure it
actually
works okay so I should be able
to edit my
information and it should save
correctly and yes it did so
hooray now this is just one controller I
know but if I have my my typical
application that I'm working with has
dozens of controllers um some of the
applications I work with have over a
hundred and if I again if I have to have
that one single line of code in every
single uh controller action uh that's
just going to blow up my code and if I
ever need to change what actually goes
on behind the scenes I'll have to go fix
that in all those different places so
let's say you need to have a policy
around saving changes to do something
like logging and the turn logging when
something fail something like that well
now I have that one spot I can go to to
be able to have that sort of
logic uh some people don't like this
because they're like it's magic because
safe changes I don't know where it's
being called but that's like 30 seconds
of conversation to clear that up or
documentation somewhere maybe and you
don't have to worry about that sort of
conversation really ever
again okay
on to the next uh so I remove save
changes from each of those now the next
thing I see is this if model state is
valid on both of my controller actions
this is the one that I I really do get
annoyed with just seeing that if model
state is valid over and over and over
and over and over again it just gets
really annoying to have to deal with
those happy path sad path for every
single form post in my
system uh one of the other thing this
that can be pretty difficult to deal
with in form posts is if the model state
is invalid and there was some validation
error now I got to worry about how to
display those errors to the end user and
here I'm just taking the the model that
I was passed in from the form poost and
straight up passing it on through the
model uh that I'm showing on The
View but that's not necessarily the same
model that I was originally hydrating
over here when I was showing the form to
begin
with and so you if you're familiar with
MVC applications and youve built a few
of these you probably have some code in
your in some of your form posts that's
like okay here's the actual form post
model let me go also hydrate some other
junk in there because not all the
information was posted up so you have
something that's like okay you got the
model then go rehydrate some of that
additional junk and go on from
there well I don't like doing that on
all my form post so what I'd like to do
is do something I did with the
transaction filter and try to get
it and remove all of my model State
valid
checks throughout the rest of my
system to do so is going to take a
little bit of finagling unfortunately um
so I actually have a diagram of what
this looks
like so if I look at a normal validation
fo in an application the normal post
redirect get will do a post to the MVC
controller it'll check to see if it's
valid or not and if it's invalid it'll
return the entire HTM payload rehydrated
with my view model back to the end user
if it is valid then I go ahead and do
the work save the changes to the
database and then I return that redirect
to the end user so they can go see the
changes that have been persisted so the
post redirect get the problem area was
this part right here I'm returning back
all the HTML to the end user and they
have to go then U I have to make sure
that uh it can properly show that HTML
based on just the form data that was
posted up through that post
flow so I'm going to flip this uh in my
modified validation flow and this is a
trick I've been using for about four
years or so my modified validation flow
is going to hijack the form post and
instead of doing like a sort of full
post it just takes the form variables
and post them up to my controller my
controller will check to see if it's
valid and this time instead of passing
back HTML of like the full form and all
the validation errors pre-rendered I'm
only returning back the error
information in the form of ajacent
object the Json object will have which
properties are invalid and also the
validation messages uh for those invalid
properties then on the client side I'll
have to take that and bind them up to
the screen somehow um and if you're
using a client side application
framework so if you're using like react
or angular or if
you're uh one of those guys using aelia
out there then all of this sort of stuff
will be more or less taken care of for
you minus the server side hookup of
getting the validation errors back to
you to be able to be shown for
you otherwise on the success path I want
it to be exactly the
same so what I want to do is hijack my
form post make an Ajax call on the
server side I'll just check to see if
model state is valid and if model state
is invalid instead of returning back
HTML in the form of the view I'll
actually just return back the errors to
the client and they can then just uh
bind them to the
screen so let's do
that first looks like my filter that's
going to be the doing the server side
validation
work okay so this is my validator action
filter and uh I don't really care what
validation framework you're using this
works for all of them really and really
what I'm try to do here is encapsulate
that flow of if model state is valid
then do the success path if model state
is invalid then do the sad path I want
to have that in exactly
one one class in my application so in my
validor Val validator action filter
which is an i action filter the on
executing method means it happens be or
during I don't know the naming is really
weird here um in this part I'll check to
see if my model state is valid if it's
not valid then what I'll do is just
straight up sterilize the model state is
the underlying validation information
inside MVC core and then just serialize
that whole object as Json so I'm not
creating some sort of intermediate
validation object I'm just saying take
whatever MC has and just shove it onto
the client and I'll go deal with it over
there so finally yep here we go so the
filter context I'll set the status code
to 400 and then I'll set the results
this content results uh over to the
filter cont context now when I replace
the result on the filter context object
that means it's going to do that result
as opposed to continue on with the
controller action so this means that my
controller actions will no longer have
to deal with the sad path of
validation okay now that I have the
nothing afterwards so now that I have
the action filter defined I want to
register its startup so over here I will
go ahead and do config filters. add
type
of validat action
filter and then finally there's a bit of
kind of ugly code and this is not it's
not ugly because the the code is all
that ugly it's just because I'm not
really that much of a front-end
developer so this is as much as I could
manage uh given my limited frontend
skills so what the front end set of code
is going to do is hijack the form post
and then take that model State errors
and then just put them on the screen
next to the right HTML elements based on
where the uh input elements uh
validation error should be I'm going to
just shove that over here in my
layout right that looks like a good
spot okay uh so I W go through the whole
thing just this one little part here
using jQuery uh it's going to hijack
every form post form and on submit it is
going
to serialize the form data right here
going to remove any validation errors
that may already exist on the
screen and then perform this Ajax
request it's going to do an Ajax request
against the existing URL the action for
that form and post up the form data as
part of the data it's going to post and
then on
success it's going
to do this right here and on error it'll
go ahead and highlight the errors now I
want to go into the Highlight errors
function it's just like low Dash code
that Loops through all the errors and
highlights the correct things on the
screen not very exciting mainly because
I don't find JavaScript code that
exciting but it it works all right so
with that front end code
there and my backend filter I can now go
back to my controller and just remove
all these really irritating if model
stateus valid checks okay so let's find
it so this is a get action it won't have
one get action won't have one get action
won't have here's a post okay so let's
just go ahead and remove that and remove
that all
right and in
my post and my edit action I'll remove
that and remove move that
lovely all right let's run this and see
what we
see all right so on my edit action just
going to do the happy path and make sure
it actually works I'll remove that I'll
hit
save
and it
broke sometimes I forget to pull in
some jQuery
[Music]
here I told you I was B at frontend
JavaScript all right well I'll come back
to this later because I don't want to
spend too much time on this other than
this works when it works when it doesn't
work well then you have to get your fun
and developer to come show you what's
wrong with it probably going through
like Chrome Dev tools or something like
that so um what I'll do is I go ahead
and remove that and just
say it works and the demo that I post up
later will have the correct code sound
good all right there's a question
yes
all right so the question is uh we'll be
covering server side validation so I
guess I should have pointed out this is
still doing server side
validation the only thing
I'm oh so what if my validation has to
do something a little bit different uh
like hit the database or something like
that um if I need to do that I won't use
the MVC core validation stuff because I
find it to be not that great and instead
I use fluent validation which actually
is dependency injection towar I won't go
through all that because that's like a
whole talk onto itself to go through
fluent validation but I would check that
out because your validation classes in
fluent validation could be registered
with dependency injection so they can
take things like a DB context to do that
database level check so in my
applications they typically have two
levels of validation one is the just
really simple form validation like is
this thing required or not and then the
complex business level validation I use
fluent validation to do that good
question
though like I said we're just going to
pretend it works and not show any more
validation
errors and I will take out this probably
really ugly JavaScript code and fix it
on
the example I'll post online later
okay so um going back to my
controller uh one other the things I
wanted to do was
uh introduce automapper as a way to get
rid of this dumb leftand side rightand
side code now anyone here use automapper
okay everybody um yeah so one of the
things I wanted to highlight are some of
the features that are kind of lesser
known to people in uh automapper land
that I think are really cool um so what
I want to do is get rid of all these but
what I don't want to do is do the old
automapper way of doing things of
loading all the properties into my do
domain model and then mapping my domain
model into my view model I'm going to be
using something else entirely now what
I've already
done is in my project Json I've already
referenced automapper as a
dependency using the latest version on
the myit because that's how I roll
something I am adding on top of this are
some extensions for Microsoft's
dependency injection framework so this
automapper extensions. micros moft
dependency injection that's a new
package that plugs in automapper with
the dependency injection container that
aspnet core uses now why is that
important well if I go back to my
startup we'll have a very similar Fe I
can do services do add
automapper there we
are so what that's done uh let me add
one more thing here type of
startup uh so what that's done behind
the scenes is uh for these different
types I've passed in it's going to be
using reflection to load up all the
types to see if they have any automap or
configuration defined in that assembly
and if it does find it it's going to
pass that in into the autom maper
initialization so that's equivalent to
me do doing something like mapper do
initialize and then adding all the
profiles Add profile and then all the
profiles my application so I I I used to
accomplish this find all the automapper
configuration via dependency injection
um and then people would do do really
horrible things like having their
profile configuration take dependencies
on like DB context and like hit the
database during configuration time which
was a really really horrible idea um but
it was enabled because that was all
configured through dependency injection
so I'm not doing that instead
I just call add automapper and any
profiles I have defined and these
assemblies that are in that type will
just be automatically loaded up and
initialized with
automapper so let's go over to our few
models and add in all the appropriate
automapper configuration we're
interested in so I'll just call this uh
student profile it's going to hear from
profile from
automapper
and some of the maps I'm interested in
are going to be let's go to our
controller uh first of all we see in our
index
action um here we are this select
projection here so I'll need a map from
student to student index
model student index model there we
are and probably one for details as well
for student to student Det
details and probably edit as
well and probably
delete as
well okay so with all the mapper
configuration oh there's a couple more
I'm going to cheat I don't normally do
this but uh the edit
action and the create action are doing
really like like very boring backwards
mapping code like really simple ones so
I usually don't recommend people to do
this but because this is a demo I can
cheat I'm going to go ahead and reverse
map these two pieces as
well uh oh just the edit one and then
finally the I'm going to create a map
from student create model into
student okay I like never do that in
actual production application but but
this is a simple one so you know I can
cheat okay so that's all the automapper
configuration I need uh the next thing
is to go back through uh my controller
and then replace all that mapping code
with the automapper code instead now the
uh the ones that are going through DB
context to use this select like
this I can replace this with project
2 student index model
and this is defined in automap or
queriable extensions and what that
project to is doing is Examining The
Source type and the Destination type so
student and student index model loading
up the automap or configuration for that
mapping and then building out this exact
select expression that the configuration
represents and what's interesting about
that is The Entity framework link query
provider interprets that select
expression it build and builds up the
exact SQL I need to be able to be to
hydrate that view
model so that means I don't actually go
from database to domain model to vew
model I go straight from database to V
model
directly so goodbye
that and down here the same
thing that that whole block of code
right there can just be project to
student details
model uh so it handles top level
properties like this it also handles
subcollections so this enrollments
enrollment select it also handles
flattening so this course. tile it
handles that as well so I can get rid of
all of that junk
goodbye other really cool thing is when
you use select projections in uh
when you select projections in OMS you
don't have to do any of that include
junk you normally see so this kind of
like dot
[Music]
include does that not exist in any frame
or
core oh my
goodness maybe it's over here
intersect there's no way it doesn't
exist I know I've seen that before maybe
it's not called include I'm not an any
framework core person because it's not a
1.0 product it's a 0.1 product um our
applications that use aspnet core run on
full.net framework and use like the real
nugate packages that actually do work
for the real world so you can still use
aspnet core on full dunet framework full
other packages that's the way that our
clients use them right now okay let's
keep
going uh this one uh this is mapping a
student crate model into a student so
let's just call A mapper
map yes pull that in uh student create
model to
student passing in the
model and that's going to return a
student so this replaces all of
that oh another projection I can get rid
of so project
to student edit model
getting rid of all this
stuff and on the reverse side the same
thing I'll map back into that original
student so mapper do map student Ed a
model to
student passing in the model and the
student so I'm hydrating an existing
object not mucking around with the
existing properties that are in
there actually that's we done I don't
even need that there we go so map the
model into the student and finally I
believe the delete action has one as
well oh here we go do project
2 student delete
Model there we
go my favorite part of my job deleting
code all right so I've replaced all of
the manual projections with automapper
based projections now the configuration
was very simple here I would caution
that if you find yourself having more
mapper configuration than autom mapped
members probably shouldn't use
automapper probably just map it manually
yourself so if I find it getting any
more complicated than sort of like
redirector members and some calculat
members I don't tend to use autom map I
just go ahead and manually do it but
this being a uh dummy application I can
do whatever I want including making the
mapping as simple as possible so
um automapper configuration is there
I've replaced all my projections with
automapper projections whether in memory
or through link and then I've also
registered automapper over here so that
I can use it throughout the rest of my
application so with all that in place
let's make sure it actually
works
all
right let's go back just refresh this
page make sure it's all Yep looks like
it's all working still I can still edit
things right edit yep uh save
it yep I fixed the validation thing so
that's working now details oop it says
I'm missing a map from
enrollment to that one oh that's right
uh some people do this they do a Apper
assert conf configuration is valid
during your application so if I did that
I would probably get that error saying
I'm missing
something oh there we go unmat members
found on the student crate model to
student uh I have some unmat properties
here so let's go fix
those oh right student model student
Crea model of students yes okay so back
in my models uh student create model to
students um by default automapper
assumes that everything on the
Destination type should be mapped it
usually thinks I'm projecting in this
case it's not it's everything on the
source type so uh for this one I'm just
going to configure automapper to say
just ignore and map everything from
actually the
source members and uh so during
configuration validation instead of
paying attention to the destination
members pay attention to the source
members uh so the question is that new
um relatively speaking yes so like four
EX four four time frame oh still got a
problem uh different one though the
enrollment cannot be mapped so there's
not a map from student details
enrollment you'd be really cool if the
exception message actually had the
configuration so you could just copy
paste I'm just making a mental note
here okay so let's go ahead and add that
configuration as well so that said
student details
model uh so there's something about
student details model dot oh that's
right that showed the collection so
enrollment to student details
enrollment oh okay so the configuration
validation worked and the detail there
we go details works
so through link project section it was
able to hydrate the top level model as
well as a collection of items as well so
even though I'm using inity framework
core it still support some pretty
complex operations it's able to support
like a one to many joined up set of data
behind the scenes now if I had SQL
profile or open I could show you the
exact query that's being run to prove to
you but the queries generated from enity
framework are so ugly we don't want to
look at them so let's
not okay so um I could go fur the with
control controllers and I usually do I
usually go through and take all of the
actual
business uh the actual business logic
that's happening and put those into
individual classes by themselves I'm
going to go through all that practice if
you want to look at the full uh there's
an entire talk dedicated to even taking
controlers further down the path but now
I want to switch gears and now take a
look at my views so up to this point
I've been mainly focused on the
controller part of my application but in
my my systems the views have just as
much duplication as the rest of my
application and people tend to ignore
that that the view is just about
rendering HTML how crazy can it get well
it can get pretty crazy but what I found
is that the abstractions actually
available in both the old MVC and the
new MVC core are not really well
equipped to handle the kind of
duplication I see on my projects so I
tend to build Enterprise applications
May it's a bad word line of business
kind of applications that are a lot of
lot of form forms of information a lot
of tables of information and people are
using this application on a daily basis
to do their jobs not so much like a like
a like a public facing web application
it's more like a behind the scenes back
office application and for those kind of
systems I'll have applications with
hundred or so controllers and then
hundreds and hundreds of actions with
hundreds and hundreds of views so
there's going to be a ton of duplication
going on with all those views going on
so instead of us using the out ofthe
boox stuff that comes with MVC core
instead what we use is a library called
HTML tags that provides a really cool
way of building out um just like how our
automapper library builds um convention
based mapping HTML tags provides us with
convention-based HTML building just like
we did on the uh back end so what does
that look like well I've already pulled
in the nougat package HTML tags.
aspnetcore so this is a version of the
HTML tags library that targeted
specifically built for asp.net
core
and in my startup I'm going to go ahead
and initialize it so I'll do
services. add HTML
tags there we
are okay so as part of this there's a
few options that I will then add
configuration to but first I want to go
to my excuse me my view to show you the
kind of duplication I'm having to deal
with and the worst one I can see is
probably the edit
one so in my edit view I have this block
of HTML that's copied let's see one
time two
times and three times and this is just
for a very simple form with three Fields
if I have a form with like a dozen or
two dozen Fields I'll have that same set
of HTML copied over and over again now I
could use something like HTML helper
extensions people you HTML helper
extensions before U the problem I see
with HTML helper extensions is that
they're all string based they're all
dealing with string based HTML content
well aspnet core introduces the concept
of tag helpers which are basically fancy
strings behind the scenes and much
harder I found to extend so our teams
took look at tagers tried to make them
work the way we build forms and found
they weren't nearly as flexible as HTML
tags and HTML tags are object based as
opposed to string
based what I mean by that is I can do
something like our tag equals new HTML
tag passing in what kind of HTML tag it
is do you want to add a class to it
there we go add a class fun time do I
want
to Ain HTML add an attribute uh all
sorts of crazy stuff so because my tag
model my HTML tag mod is now object base
I can now start to inject some smarts
into how these HTML tags are built so
let me get rid of all this okay so I'm
GNA do some more copy paste from my
cheat
sheet oh I remember what I forgot I
didn't look at my cheat sheet I'm for my
valid example Should Have Cheated
cheaters always
win okay so first I'm going to modify my
initial initialization just a little
bit uh and I'm going to be adding in
these different convention uh classes um
this default HTML conventions is what
comes with HTML tags it's all the HTML
conventions for NVC applications so the
way way to build input elements and uh
you know booleans being checkboxes
things like that that comes from that
base set of configuration there and I'm
going to add on top of it more
convenance
in this class right here I'm just going
to stick it right next to it because you
can do inner classes okay so what I'm
going to do is side by side slowly make
changes to my tag reg my tag my
tag configur ation until it matches
exactly what the existing uh editor does
and then go from there and make it even
more smart even smarter even more smart
smarter okay so uh back in my edit
action I've got this editor for blah
blah blah that's using uh it's using uh
editor templates which again are anyone
tried to make custom editor templates
it's like stupid hard to try to do that
it's ridiculous so they're all Razer
based and you can't do like really any
actual code logic in there it's just
just a kind of a nightmare to deal with
um and so I can do this instead so I'll
do
html. input oh before I do that I'm
going to go to my view
Imports and do at using HTML
tags
dot
conventions dot conventions and I think
just HTML tags as well um this is a new
thing in NBC core uh to have Global
Imports across all your views that's
what the view Imports file does you used
to had to go to that web config file
that thing's gone you use this thing
instead html. input there we are that
was not there before and I give it the
expression for the model so exactly what
I have before input model. last name
okay let's go ahead and run this and see
what we
see
all right back over here let me go ahead
and click edit and we should see it look
a little bit funny but I've got this
over here and I got the this is the new
one and this is the old one on the right
so it's already been able to do like the
model binding stuff to put the correct
piece in there I don't have to worry
about those pieces those are all coming
from the uh the integration with asp.net
core
now if I go look at the HTML though I
will see some slight
differences uh let's go and inspect this
element that one and I see it's input
type equals text value equals Alexander
this one oh that's more it's got like
input class textbox single line blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
a whole bunch of other stuff on top of
that so what I'll be doing is adding
those extra conventions on top of it so
that all that other information comes in
as
well
okay so back in
my startup my configuration for my tags
I'm going to go ahead and add for my
cheat sheet this right
here
no here we go so this is saying that my
editors will always add the class form
control which I think is the old
bootstrap version but that's okay what
do this have input class equals
text-box even though it's input type
equals text we have to be extra redund
it here so let's do that instead of form
control I'll
have text now let's just leave form
control that's
fine okay so refresh this
page and
now oh it still
has the old version of it oh it's
because it's an editor okay I'll get
there in a
second uh the next one I want to add on
top of it
is my dat times should always have this
configuration associated with
it
so oh let me get rid of that pattern I
don't want
that don't want that either those are
extensions that I don't actually want
here um okay and short date string does
that not exist it's okay we'll
do two string and which kind of string
is it going to be it's going to be the
short date that
one okay so what this is saying is if it
finds a property of type dat time
nullable date time is going to modify
that by adding the date picker class on
top of it and then the value if it has a
value is going to make sure it formats
with a short date kind of
format so back in my
view if I now go
replace this editor for with
inputs this one up here as
well we'll again see what we
see
okay so if I go look at this element
now I remember what I
forgot I forgot to cheat again um back
in my startup I forgot to actually add
this convention to my list of libraries
so I need actually do new MVC core HTML
conventions okay so it pulled in the
default ones and then adding on top of
it are mine okay that makes me less
confused
now all right let's refresh this and now
we should see now all my conventions now
oh there we go so now it's adding on top
that form control bootstrap style that
put the little rounded corners on top of
it the short date format here which I'm
sorry on my laptop is month day Year
sorry
uh and putting all the uh appropriate
styling on top of everything and I can
keep going with this I can then go pull
in all the View kind of
conventions and label conventions as
well so let me pull those in
here
and custom category of kind of tags
that's what this piece is here I'm just
going to paste it all in so I can show
the final product which is going to
be my
view oh let's not do that
one okay so all this configuration is
for telling the HTML tag Library when
you see this kind of request to build
this kind of tag modify it with this
configuration here so the policy about
how to build HTML tags is in one spot in
my application right here and if I need
to add on top of it additional ways of
building HTML tags again it all goes
back to here I'm going to go take this
one step
further and that I'm going
to create some HTML helper
extensions to build
out and let's just put this at the root
oh helpers here we
go
uh here we go this one right
here
and oh no that's not the one that's
ugly
okay ah there we go should pull
everything in IH HTML
hurn there we go so now what I can do
with this input block that is building
out the surrounding HTML I had earlier
and this form block as well I can now go
back to my view and actually
replace all of this with html. form
block oh form
lock Nam space is wrong let's
[Music]
do there we go just made something up
there we go form Block M goes to m. last
name and I'll have two more of those
uh first name first midn name and
enrollment date and that actually gets
rid of all of
this and what I'm doing right now is
just really building policies about how
these different form tags should be
shown
oop I just get rid of these display ones
that's
fine um and making sure that whenever I
want to display a form block on a page
it always goes to that one single spot
and because it's all object based in the
HTML tags it makes it super easy to
compose out those individual models so
me refresh this and it should look
exactly the
same it's got the label it's got the
input element the validation messages on
the side and because it's all based off
objects it makes it super easy for me to
in my extension method compose
up different sets of HTML tags with
different information pushing them all
together into one single HTML tag to
show to the end
user is that cool or no okay so that
library is called HTML tags it's plugged
into aset core and I use the plugin to
aset core plus some conventions to
define a single policy for how HTML tags
should be displayed throughout the
entirety of my application no more
arguments about use this day peaker use
that that day peaker oh this label
should be above it or behind it nope we
have a single policy in a single place
place
so that was solid as. netcore my name is
Jimmy you can find me at Twitter atj
boggards everything you'll see here
including the right working example will
be on github.com J Bogard uh all this
kind of topics I blog at Los techies and
one of the things I'm doing is building
a video course doing exactly this if
you're interested about that go to that
bitly link right there and you can sign
up for the video course that basically
walks through exactly all these things
uh that we just went through thank you
very much I hope you enjoyed this and
have a great rest of the
conference